one of the things I'm saying in soar is
don't waste time I'd rather see you
waste money than to waste time you can
get some more money I could give you
some money you could give me some money
we could hook her up we can hook you up
you'll be all right I can't give you not
one day if you need it I can't give you
30 seconds if you need it so the the
prime commodity is your time and when
you are young you take it for granted
because you think you're gonna always
have plenty of it you might have more of
it you might not and if you do have it
nothing says you're going to feel like
look like move like you do right now
what you do have is this present moment
so if you want to change your diet
you can change your outcome
but you have to stop talking to yourself
the way you do
because if you continue to talk to
yourself the way you do you will always
be where you've always been
it is what you say within yourself that
heals you because the reality about it
is your definition of excellent Rises no
higher than your level of exposure
whatever you've been exposed to that
becomes the new paradigm of what
excellent is to you
any shifts from day to day the reality
is
we have to make up in our mind
that whatever our definition of
Excellence is
called change
that kind of talk saying that to
yourself drives back the other voices of
negativity that we all have creep up
behind us and tell us that we're not
capable and we're not competent and
we're not gifted enough and we're not
good enough and we waited too late or
God is punishing us
[Music]
to talk back to those voices shut the
enemy down
the pressure I was going through
I was causing
because the pressure I was going through
was coming from the things that I
allowed to reverberate in my head
and I'm wondering if there are things
echoing in your head right now that are
stopping you from living your best life
because you will not silence him by
speaking back I found out it is not what
they say about you that limits you the
most is that you might believe them
and start saying that to yourself
and and uh there were many many many
people who said that I would never be
anything
uh I just chose not to be one of them at
as long as it's not your mouth that says
it you can overcome theirs all day long
and uh Destiny is something that we
grope after Providence and purpose is
something that that we see through a
very dark glass and some of the most
momentous moments in my life I stumbled
into roping to understand
uh why am I here
and and who am I really and I think that
that those questions to me are more
important than than answers the world is
a university and everyone in it is a
teacher when you wake up in the morning
be sure you go to school and I've been
doing that all of my life yeah I've
learned from everybody I ever met good
or bad right or wrong I learned
something I think periodically wherever
there is purpose and wherever there is
resistance to that purpose pressure
release us from that resistance and the
more that we yield to the process but
the problem today is that we don't
preach process
we we preach promises
so we have raised a generation of people
who who see God in promises not process
you see it depends on Whose perspective
it's like a husband and wife live in the
same house have same address eat the
same food but they're having two
different experiences and so the point
of view determines uh the the relativity
of the truth the power the truth the
significance of the truth is all brought
about by who's talking I have always
been relentless
I never allowed my circumstances
to destroy my intensity and my drive and
my feeling that God was going to do
something in my life
success that you have not been groomed
for it's like having birthing a baby
prematurely
the chances of survival go down the
earlier the baby is exposed and to be
exposed too soon is not a blessing it's
curse you you don't want anything before
it's time
nothing before it's time there's a time
and a season for every purpose under
heaven and so anything that's valuable
you you protect and in that fast pace
that we live in there is a certain
amount of invisible pressure and the
strange thing about it is you feel the
pain
you sense the pressure and you can't see
the source
so all of a sudden you're getting the
impact as if there were an assailant but
there's no assailant that you can see
and this the seeds always hint to us
then life comes out of death as the
outer encasement corrodes in the ground
they enter life bursts forth and
everything that dies in you is only so
that something else can be born in you
yeah and it is the urgency of of a
fleeting moment the Escape out of pain
is a fleeting moment it is passing by
and if you're not willing to come out of
your coat and drop your cup and and step
into that moment blindly yeah without
understanding it without somebody
apologizing without somebody coming back
and making it right this is not about
them this is about you
this is about you when you are truly
gifted
you can't see it
when you are truly gifted when you are
truly gifted it is your normal and so
the frustration is you're trying to
manifest your gift and you are
manifesting your gift but you don't know
that that is your gift because your gift
is your normal so sometimes the more
gifted you are the more vulnerable you
are and the more affirmation you need
from your inner circle
sometimes people will call you a name
and you start living up to the name and
it limits you from what else God wants
to do in your life
and an appreciation for the value of
life and a refusal to allow anybody to
take away the great privilege of being
alive
I will think for myself
I will move in my own Direction you can
say whatever you want to say about it
but I'm going to be me you see what I'm
saying yeah at the core of everything
soar is saying don't be limited don't
put a period because you you did one
thing that you can't do something else
that you can't be something else that
you can't evolve as an individual that
you can't explore other idioms of
thought you came from the dirt and where
you came from will always call you back
you have to escape the gravitational
pull of where you came from and in order
to do that you have to break through
into a higher law the higher law is the
law of aerodynamics
but you have to break into it and what I
need the force for the reason I need the
runway to get my engines ramped up is
because when I come up against it and
this is where young people make a
mistake they underestimate the pull to
fall backwards they saw planes take off
and they said I can do that but they
underestimate how much force it takes to
break through the gravitational pull
that brings you back down so when they
fall back down they give up on
themselves and they stop believing
themselves whereas if you would just go
faster at it and go harder at it you
would break through the law of gravity